We're in.
And I'm going to move my stop to here. I
think if it pushes all the way up
kind of sucks that it one ticked me and
then it's pulling back, but
either way, anything can happen. Even on
the the 15-minute chart here.
I think this looks great as
testing this trend line, testing this
resistance.
Um and you know, doing this kind of
move.
My initial target is going to be here.
Wow, that's a nice spike. Nasdaq spiked
as well.
It's spiking all the way if it reverses
this whole candlestick
that's gross.
It reversing a huge spike like that
usually means
something bad.
I'm going to at least bring this down to
half and probably try to go break even
pretty quickly.
But I do want to give it a little bit
the ability to come up here
you know, spike up somewhere here
and then go down.
You know, maybe like there's this
downtrend line in play.
Here. Wow, that's a nice
If it comes down here and retests this
low, I'm going to go break even.
Just because this market's funky. Um
I want to stay in the move obviously cuz
I think I think there's more downside
than just 2x here.
Uh I'd love to go for the lows.
But
you know, if it if it's just going to be
funky, I'm not going to stay in.
Um ES, Nasdaq here looks the same.
It's kind of doing the same thing,
pushing lower. It looks looks good.
Again, here's the 5-minute of the
Nasdaq. I'm looking for this to close
and maybe open the door to down here.
The ES is the exact same.
This is the easy money right here, and
then I like it to go and push down here.
So, we're going to see I'm not going to
I'm not going to trail my stop up here
yet. I'm just going to see how this
reacts to this zone
cuz it's it's more likely that it's like
this. It's kind of a more minor support.
I'm going to [clears throat] move this
stop now to break even.
Just because
if it does a double bottom here, get me
out, you know? That's that's a big
pullback after um a spike. As well, if
you're not aware of this, NinjaTrader is
having a $20,000
demo trading challenge. You can
basically sign up for free if you're a
new NinjaTrader person or currently
using NinjaTrader. It just takes an
email, and it's essentially a free demo
trading tournament that you can win
actual real money from. The prize pool
is $20,000.
Uh it's over a couple days. Essentially,
you just demo trade for those few days
under a special account they create, and
then you get real money prizes. So, it's
pretty cool.
I'll leave the link for that down in the
description below, or here's a QR code
to sign up. Now, managing this
I mean, I think I'm just going to I'm
trying to just kind of let it play out,
you know? It was slow.
This is a nice break, but I'm assuming
because it's been sluggish here
it's most likely going to stay doing
that. So, I want to um
let it do its thing, you know? Because
the big picture I think big picture like
this is a great spike lower.
Um
and I think it it could totally, you
know, big picture again, remember big
big picture is I think bullish.
But, I think it's bullish
you know, once it's we come down to this
area. That's more of the support area.
And so, in the middle here, it's kind of
like just seeing
how it plays out. Um you know, if it
comes up here and gets me out at break
even,
so be it. I think my stop's in a good
spot here
um, with
you know, back at the at the main break.
If it's going to come up here and knock
me out,
I'll be upset, but I think
you know, I don't I don't want to stay
in the chop and and risk when I think
the market just isn't great for a trade.
Um,
especially after this
pullback happening right here. If it
comes up here and breaks this, I'm very
very happy to get out cuz it's done a
double bottom here.
Um,
and you know, attempted to go higher and
if it comes back and and breaks that
attempt, it's going to definitely go
higher here.
And I, you know, I want to get out at
that point. The idea is that this should
be going in my favor pretty easily.
And it's, you know, I've given it room
for some pullback, some reasonable
pullbacks, and if it breaks that,
you know, like this is what I've looking
for essentially. I I'm okay holding
through a pullback like that. It's it's
hard to stomach, you know, a $1,500
swing,
but, you know, that's where trading over
time you just get better and better at
that with sizing up. You know, I
couldn't do this
2 3 years ago. I couldn't stomach seeing
this much money move on the screen, but
now it's, you know, I I I don't really
focus on it. I'm more just thinking
about, you know, okay, how do I want to
manage it because the size isn't crazy
to me anymore.
And so, that's a great pullback and
spike. I could even move this down here.
It doesn't really capture much, but
that's just, you know, how my plan and
strategy works. I like to move down with
the swings.
And then obviously remembering that
we're
coming to this as a minor support.
But again, I think it's I think we've
got good potential to keep going lower.
Um, I'm definitely going to give it, you
know, a few candlesticks
to see how we play out.
I'm seeing this much money.
This could totally spike up here and
knock me out basically at break even,
but um you know, that's how it goes,
right? Uh
That's the hard part about why it's you
know, I basically entered in halfway
through this swing,
which isn't ideal,
but that's just how this swing played
out. And so, that's why the idea is I
don't want to scale out here because
um you know, I'm nervous that it's going
to pull back. If it if it starts slow
and show a double bottom, you know, I'll
start to scale this down.
But, you know, my play here is the
bigger picture that we're going to
actually push the lows. And that's
where, you know, the risk reward comes
into play, and that's why
this trade was worth the risk is because
of that bigger picture downside.
If I was just going for this little
scalp right here, I I wouldn't want to
do that. And that that's why I'm not
scaling out necessarily.
Um it looks like almost we could say
we're in a spikier downtrend here, but
just I'm not going to draw that as a
line just to keep the chart kind of
clean.
Um but definitely going to I guess I
could maybe do this.
But just kind of watching it.
See how we move.
Just letting this do its thing. So, the
ES has filled this move, and the Nasdaq
actually hasn't made it there yet.
So, that's one thing of Okay, well, the
Nasdaq foot could actually find support
here.
And as well as thinking as we're
actually coming we're at the 10:00
timing,
which could also cause a bounce here.
So, just keeping a lot of that in mind
of
the potential for
a bounce. But again, just let it play
out, how it acts versus trying to
get nervous about that. You know, I I
want the market to tell me that it's
going to bounce
versus trying to get scared and think,
"Oh, it could bounce here because of
these reasons."
It's not showing me that it's bouncing
yet. You know, this is just a a steady
move lower. Now, it is kind of losing
some steam. You know, here it had a
spike and then the spikes are kind of
getting smaller. So, it could start to
flatline a little, but it also could
just start to accelerate here as it
you know, breaks through this support.
So, just kind of got to let it do its
thing, right? As as always.
When you're in a trade and managing, you
just got to
sit on your hands and and try not to
overthink things.
That's uh the hard part about managing
trades fluidly.
That just again gets easier over time.
showing me that it's bouncing. And even
when we get down to this low,
I will I'm actually going to move this
up a little bit just so I can see on the
1-minute kind of where this
fair value gap spike closes.
Um
but even on this 1-minute like I'm I'm
going to get out here down here
essentially at 3x. I might just move it
just to um
so I'm up over 5,000 on the trade just
for a fun number.
But you know, my limit is I I'll I'll
probably just move that down as we get
closer, you know, I'll move this down. I
mean, I'll I'll move this down to here.
Um I I wouldn't necessarily get out
here. I'm just using it's more of a
mental trailing stop of seeing, "Okay,
how does this spike now play out? Does
it get overextended and it's going to
reverse quickly?
Or do I just need to
wait it out and let it do its thing. You
know, we're in this tight downtrend, so
it's really still
um just kind of looking looking normal
here.
But if we
spike all the way down to 3x here, I'll
probably move to a previous candlestick
trailing stop. I like that as a way to
basically capture the move without
allowing it to spike back much, but also
letting it run as much as it's going to
run. Cuz these moves, you know, the
market can go crazy
all of a sudden. You know, it can just
all of a sudden just
go berserk on you.
Um and it's starting I think once we
maybe one more candlestick I'll move to
trailing stop.
Um
the Nasdaq looks pretty similar.
Is it's it's actually broken this area.
It's hard when it's it's made most of
this move and that's spiking and it's
not to
you know, my 3x target yet. I really
like to try and ratchet when it gets to
3x.
I think though I can move down to here.
Cuz usually when the market has a big
bearish candlestick like this,
um
the high of that candlestick is a good
stop. Cuz it's if it breaks the high of
that, it's definitely going to reverse.
Um just because that's a lot of momentum
came in there. Um
and and if this keeps going down, I'm
I'm just going to start trailing this
down.
And you know, if if I get knocked out
here because it you know, it bottoms, it
bottoms, you know, I'm not trying to go
for I like to target down here.
But again, we're we're at the support
zone, right? Like I got to
think about that's the main spot I'm at.
Um
and that's kind of where
you know, I I I I I see the potential
for the market to reverse.
Cuz this is where kind of the glory of a
fluid stop loss can come into play
is when it just starts to go crazy like
this.
Um, and I'm just going to, you know,
keep again just keep moving it down like
this. It doesn't happen very often, but
it when it does
it can be very exciting. Um,
I'm just trying to
you know, my my heart rate is getting
excited now because this is exciting,
you know,
um,
we're pretty much at the area of of
I've never had a trade over 5K
um, win at this size. So, this is
exciting, but also trying to just say,
"Okay, you know, I'm I'm just trying to
stick with my strategy here of previous
trailing stop candlestick." This is
getting big now.
But, I've learned over time is just keep
the stop there and I'll try and let it
have a 50% pullback.
But, again this is spiking to the
downside. So, again
it does have that big chance to whip
back. So,
I want to see this candlestick whip back
a little bit. That's okay if it punches
a new low, and then I'll, you know, move
my stop down again.
>> [clears throat]
>> I'd like it to make a new low.
Okay, I'm making a new low. I'm going to
pull my stop down again. Again, I'm not
going to
I'm pretty much just moving my limit
order down.
I I'm not going to really let it get
filled. Sometimes I just won't even have
the limit order.
Um, but it's just on my chart now, so
I'm just going to leave it.
NASDAQ has actually hit the low So,
we're we've broken the lows here on a
ES.
And then the NASDAQ has just hit the
lows. It hasn't broken the lows yet.
So that's what I'm watching there.
Just kind of waiting for this to do its
move. Again, it might have a watching it
do a 50% pullback from the lows. Maybe
it comes up to this low and bounces.
I'm trying not to think the fact that
I'm up 6K on the trade.
I've locked in
over 5K. So
biggest trade ever so far. So that's
really exciting.
And this is where, you know, it it might
have a pullback here and it might get
out. And that's totally fine. You know,
I want to hold through it doing
this, but if it as soon as it starts to
show some strength, it can do this.
That's how these moves work.
And so, you know, I'm letting it do its
pullback here. It looks like it's going
to knock me out like 5,100 or something.
>> [sighs]
>> Yep, we're out. Sick trade.
You know, it's always like, "Oh, maybe
if I give it a little bit of more room,
I can stay in longer."
But you know, look at how fast it just
spiked up here.
This candlestick, you know, I stop My
stop was like a thousand dollars
in reality, which is a lot.
Um
but it's, you know, that's
did exactly what I wanted to do.
Sick trade. Super happy with that. And
that's why I don't um use this downtrend
line anymore cuz if you think about it,
holding to see if it tests this
downtrend line, that would be giving
back literally half of the profit on the
trade.
Um and so
I don't want to do that, you know,
because generally when it gets so
overextended, it's just going to rip
back.
And then when it usually happens, it's
like, "Okay, the trend's probably over."
Um or it's it's adjusting and it it
could just, you know, it's just
this is what I found over time as the
simplest thing to to work out. So,
make sure to check out that NinjaTrader
competition in the link below.
Otherwise, happy trading.